Well, in this moment of our presidential election process, let us consider the plight of a group whose sad fate we do not usually consider, a group we do not usually count among society's victims. I refer to moderate Republicans, because they have seen the future. And the future has a name. And the future's name is Bob Dole, the man now invariably referred to as the presumptive nominee, except of course by himself. He always refers to himself as Bob Dole.
在这个总统选举进程的当下，让我们来审视一群平时很少被我们考虑、也往往不被列为社会受害者的人。我指的是温和派共和党人，因为他们已经看到了未来。而未来有一个名字，那就是鲍勃·多尔（Bob Dole），也就是现在大家口中所谓的“准候选人”，当然，他自己除外。他总是自称为“鲍勃·多尔”。
And they are a pragmatic, roll up your sleeves, get the job done group, as a whole, the moderate Republicans are. And they will do what is necessary for victory in the fall to get the White House. But just last week, when we convened a small, unscientific panel of four Republicans, only one of the four was actually happy about the presumptive nominee.
他们总体上是一群务实、挽起袖子就能干活的人。为了在秋季大选中获胜并入主白宫，他们愿意做一切必要的事。但就在上周，当我们召集了一个由四名共和党人组成的小型非正式小组时，四个人中只有一个对这位准候选人感到满意。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it is Your Radio Playhouse. I'm Ira Glass. In our program today, politics, economics, you know, the big picture.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《你的广播剧场》（Your Radio Playhouse），我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是政治、经济，也就是那些宏观课题。
And later on in our program, we hire two temp workers. And we put them to work doing a radio story about being temp workers. And these guys aren't office workers. These guys are part of the massive number of workers in our country right now who do temp work in factories and industrial settings.
在节目稍后，我们会雇佣两名临时工，让他们制作一篇关于“当临时工是什么感觉”的广播报道。这些人不是办公室职员，他们是目前我国工厂和工业环境下从事临时工作的庞大劳动大军的一部分。
That will be Act Two. That means later. Because right now, we're on Act One, Presumptiveness.
那是第二幕的内容，也就是稍后的部分。因为现在，我们正处于第一幕：推定候选人。
The Republicans we convened for our panel were these people, and gave very generously of their time, I should say, because the power went out in Navy Pier in the middle of our interviews. So these people not only-- we started our interview, then we had to take them out for drinks, and then we had to bring them back. So this is not just presumptiveness, but it's presumptiveness on the rocks. That's what this segment is.
我们召集的小组成员非常慷慨地贡献了他们的时间。我得说，因为在采访中途，海军码头（Navy Pier）突然停电了。所以这些人不仅参加了采访——我们刚开始，就不得不带他们出去喝了杯酒，然后又把他们带回来。所以这不仅仅是关于“推定候选人”，这是“处于困境中的推定候选人”，这正是这一节的主题。
Our Republicans were [? Will Tinken, ?] a bonds trader, Diane Cohen, an attorney who is, I think it'd be more accurate to describe her as a libertarian than a moderate Republican, but still shared some views with these guys. [? Brian Castle, ?] a bonds trader and money manager and 43rd Ward Republican committeeman. And Dan Parisi, who owns a pizza restaurant out in the suburbs and also works as a telephone technician for Ameritech. And as of last Tuesday, this was Junior Tuesday, before Super Tuesday, before the New York primary, before Bob Dole was fully named the presumptive nominee, Will was the only one of the four people in our panel who would look you square in the eye and actually say he had a favorite candidate.
我们的共和党成员包括：债券交易员威尔·廷肯；我认为将黛安·科恩描述为自由意志主义者比温和派共和党人更准确，但她仍与这些人持有部分共同观点；债券交易员兼资金经理、第 43 区共和党委员布莱恩·卡斯尔；还有丹·帕里西，他在郊区拥有一家比萨店，同时也是 Ameritech 的电话技术员。在上周二之前，也就是“小周二”，在“超级周二”之前，在纽约初选之前，在鲍勃·多尔被正式提名为准候选人之前，威尔是小组中唯一一个能直视你的眼睛，坦言自己有心仪候选人的人。
Dole. And the reason I like Dole is I just like the way he's held together in this past month. Talk about a trial by fire. His resume is impressive. He's got a unique perspective. And dare I say, I might be excited by Bob Dole.
多尔。我喜欢多尔的原因是，我喜欢他在过去一个月里的沉稳表现。这可谓是一场烈火考验。他的简历令人印象深刻，他有独特的视角。我甚至敢说，我对鲍勃·多尔感到兴奋。
Smiles all around, I should say for people in the radio audience. Everyone else at the table just had a little grin. And there was a sort of rolling of eyes from Diane. Diane?
我得说，在广播听众面前，大家都笑了。桌上的其他人只是微微一笑，黛安甚至翻了个白眼。黛安？
I'm just in denial. I'm waiting for Jack Kemp to announce. So I'll pass on that.
我只是在逃避现实。我在等杰克·肯普宣布参选。所以我对此不予置评。
So you're having trouble finding a candidate who you like.
所以你很难找到一个你喜欢的候选人。
Yes. They don't represent the ideals that brought me into the Republican Party. Ronald Reagan brought me in. And candidates I see are just not inspiring me in the same way.
是的。他们代表不了把我吸引进共和党的那些理想。罗纳德·里根把我带了进来，而现在我看到的候选人无法以同样的方式激励我。
Brian?
布莱恩？
Well, I had liked Governor Pete Wilson of California early on, and so I was probably the most wrong person here at the panel, as he went out quickly. But I think Bob Dole would probably be a very good president. And I like Forbes as well.
我起初很喜欢加州州长皮特·威尔逊，所以在这个小组里，我可能是最看走眼的人，因为他很快就退出了。但我认为鲍勃·多尔可能会是一位非常好的总统。我也很喜欢福布斯。
Dan, what about you? Are you having trouble finding a candidate you can love?
丹，你呢？你很难找到一个让你爱上的候选人吗？
I wish that Bob Dole could get as excited about Bob Dole as Will has gotten about Bob Dole.
我希望鲍勃·多尔能像威尔支持他那样，对他自己也感到兴奋。
At the time, Dan and Brian were still deciding between Dole and Forbes. Diane described herself as "off the map," no candidate at all. They all said they wanted the next president to be somebody who would reduce the size of government, cut regulations. Brian and Dan were especially forceful about the idea of eliminating the federal deficit. And so I proposed a theoretical candidate to our panel, somebody who would balance the federal budget in just a few years, somebody who promises to reduce the size of government and cut the capital gains tax, somebody who is for the death penalty and tougher sentences for juvenile offenders, somebody who is pro-choice. All four of them said they would at least be curious to hear more about such a candidate. Or as Diane put it--
当时，丹和布莱恩还在多尔和福布斯之间纠结。黛安形容自己“完全脱离圈子”，没有支持任何人。他们都说希望下一任总统能是一个减少政府规模、削减监管的人。布莱恩和丹对消除联邦赤字的想法尤为坚定。于是，我向小组提出了一个理论上的候选人：一个能在短短几年内平衡联邦预算、承诺减少政府规模、削减资本利得税、支持死刑、对青少年犯罪处以更严厉刑罚，并且支持堕胎权的人。他们四个人都表示至少有兴趣了解更多关于这样一位候选人的信息。或者正如黛安所说——
Well, I'd like to hear what she has to say.
好吧，我想听听她（他）怎么说。
And then I revealed to them that this theoretical candidate, the person who I was describing to them as an acceptable moderate Republican, was, if you haven't guessed this already, President Clinton. This is where he stands on these issues.
随后我向他们透露，这位理论上的候选人，我所描述的那位“合格的温和派共和党人”，其实就是克林顿总统。这就是他在这些议题上的立场。
Is that where he stands this week?
那是他这周的立场吗？
Want to elaborate on that point? Everybody around the table, again, smiled.
想针对这一点详细说说吗？桌上的每个人再次笑了。
I'll echo what Dan says. We may agree with a lot of the positions that President Clinton carries today. And again, I say today. But we don't know where he'll be tomorrow. I don't happen to believe that President Clinton is as high of integrity person that we should have in the White House. I think that most of the Republican candidates right now do hold that integrity. And I'd rather see one of them in there.
我附和丹的观点。我们可能同意克林顿总统今天持有的许多立场。再次强调，是“今天”。但我们不知道他明天会是什么样。我不认为克林顿总统具备我们入主白宫者应有的高尚品格。我认为目前大多数共和党候选人确实具备这种品格，我宁愿看到他们中的一位入驻。
Will?
威尔？
I can't think of anybody in the field right now, the Republican field, that would not do better than President Clinton with the same views.
我实在想不出目前共和党阵营里有哪个人，在持有相同观点的情况下，会做得比克林顿总统更差。
For many people, the coming presidential election is a lot like the last one in one significant way. For these people, there is only one issue. They do not like Bill Clinton. But maybe, maybe, moderate Republicans could be persuaded over to Bill Clinton's side, the way that moderate Democrats in droves, in masses, in national waves, were persuaded over to Ronald Reagan's side and George Bush's side-- once, anyway. I enlisted a little help to find out.
对许多人来说，即将到来的总统选举在某一方面与上次非常相似。对这些人来说，只有一个议题：他们不喜欢比尔·克林顿。但也许，也许温和派共和党人能被说服倒向比尔·克林顿一边，就像温和派民主党人成群结队、大规模地被说服倒向罗纳德·里根和乔治·布什一边一样——至少曾经有过。我找了点帮手来一探究竟。
OK, well, joining us now by telephone is Gary LaPaille, who's state chairman of the Democratic party. Gary LaPaille, are you there?
好的，现在通过电话加入我们的是民主党州主席加里·拉佩尔。加里·拉佩尔，你在吗？
I'm here.
我在。
All right. So you're there. So Gary LaPaille, let me just review for a second. The four Republicans who are seated here with me have conceded that when it comes to the issues, many of President Clinton's stands and promises are fine with them. But when it comes to him the man, they are perhaps not so comfortable. Do you want to try to sell them on the idea for a second?
好的。加里·拉佩尔，让我回顾一下。在座的四位共和党人都承认，在议题上，克林顿总统的许多立场和承诺对他们来说是可以接受的。但谈到他个人时，他们似乎不太舒服。你想试着说服他们一下吗？
Absolutely.
当然。
OK.
好的。
Well, this is a person that is probably the first generation, our generation, that has become president. And our generation, I think it's our time to provide the leadership of this nation. You [UNINTELLIGIBLE] to a Bob Dole, he's had his time. He's had some--
好吧，这是第一代，也就是我们这一代，成为总统的人。我认为，由我们这一代来领导这个国家是时候了。你提到鲍勃·多尔，他的时代已经过去了。他有一些——
Now I should say that at this point, the panel looked around at each other, and everybody was shaking their heads. This was clearly not working with our panel. And this might seem like an odd approach for Gary LaPaille to take.
我得说，此时小组里的成员互相看了看，大家都在摇头。这招显然对我们的小组不管用。对加里·拉佩尔来说，这似乎是一个奇怪的策略。
But according to newspaper reports, to differentiate President Clinton and Bob Dole, who share many of the same stands on many issues, White House officials are saying that they're going to play up the age and generation difference. Gary LaPaille is basically giving us a preview here of what we're going to be hearing throughout the next few months as we get into the general election. Gary LaPaille is saying what basically any leading Democratic politician will be saying about the president at this moment. And what was interesting about it was it was not persuasive with our panel.
但据报纸报道，为了区分克林顿总统和在许多议题上立场相同的鲍勃·多尔，白宫官员表示他们将利用年龄和代际差异。加里·拉佩尔基本上是在为我们在未来几个月进入大选时会听到的内容打个样。加里·拉佩尔所说的，基本上是任何领先的民主党政客在此时此刻都会谈论总统的方式。有趣的是，这对我们的小组并没有说服力。
Gary, I agree that he is of course of a certain Baby Boom generation. But that's no excuse for some of the things. But I guess what Ira was saying before was we agreed with some of his positions today. But they're not positions he necessarily held six months ago, a year ago, or two years ago. How do you answer the question that he doesn't stand on the issues firmly?
加里，我同意他确实是婴儿潮一代。但这不能成为某些事情的借口。但我猜艾拉之前说的是，我们今天同意他的一些立场。但这些并不一定是他在六个月前、一年前或两年前持有的立场。你如何回答他立场不够坚定这个问题？
Well, I would have to say that when he first got into office, the first six months, we stood very firmly and got this economy back on track and put a plan in place, supported by only Democrats, that has reduced this deficit three years in a row, first time since Harry Truman, and has reduced it by over 50%. That was the whole debate in 1992, and we did it--
好吧，我不得不说，当他刚上任的前六个月，我们非常坚定地使经济回到正轨，并实施了一项仅由民主党支持的计划。该计划已连续三年削减了赤字，这是哈里·杜鲁门以来的首次，而且削减幅度超过了 50%。这就是 1992 年的辩论焦点，我们做到了——
A brisk discussion of the economy followed this. People were astonishingly well informed, I should say. They threw around budget numbers and dates and specifics about the first Clinton budget and the second Clinton budget and consequences for Social Security.
接下来是一场关于经济的快节奏讨论。我得说，人们对数据的掌握令人震惊。他们抛出预算数字、日期，以及关于第一个克林顿预算和第二个克林顿预算的细节，还有对社会保障的影响。
And what was interesting was that none of the Republicans gave President Clinton any of the credit for the eight million jobs created over the last four years, or the rising stock market, or the record number of new small business starts. Our panelists said that the normal business cycle would've done all of that anyway. They pointed out that among these jobs were a disproportionate number of low-wage jobs.
有趣的是，没有一个共和党人把过去四年创造的八百万个就业岗位、上涨的股市或创纪录的小企业开办数量归功于克林顿总统。小组成员说，正常的商业周期无论如何都会带来这一切。他们指出，在这些工作中，低薪工作的比例偏高。
And even the one area where President Clinton did stick his neck out, on his first budget, which did make dramatic cuts in the federal deficit, even here, they gave the president no credit. The cuts were not deep enough and not done with real conviction on his part, they said. Gary LaPaille, however, kept trying.
即使是在克林顿总统确实冒险的领域——他的第一个预算案，确实大幅削减了联邦赤字，即便如此，他们也没有给总统任何功劳。他们说，削减幅度不够深，而且他本人缺乏真正的信念。然而，加里·拉佩尔一直在尝试。
Even the federal budget, people say, "Oh, well, Democrats are big spenders. And we've got to cut government." Right now, under Bill Clinton, we have the lowest federal government workforce since the days of John F. Kennedy, 270,000 less federal employees under this president from the day he took office. So something's working. He's agreed to balance his budget in seven years.
即使是联邦预算，人们也会说，“哦，民主党是大手大脚的人。我们必须削减政府开支。”现在，在比尔·克林顿领导下，联邦政府雇员人数达到了约翰·肯尼迪时代以来的最低水平，比他上任时减少了 27 万名员工。所以还是有成效的。他已经同意在七年内平衡预算。
Gary Lapelle, I'm afraid I don't think you're winning many converts here. People are shaking their heads no. I've tried to deliver you four potential voters, but I don't believe that you've brought them home.
加里·拉佩尔，恐怕你在这里赢不到多少支持者。人们都在摇头。我试着为你带来了四名潜在选民，但我不认为你已经把他们争取过来了。
We may be right on all the issues regarding pro-choice. We may be right on some of the economic policies to go after moderate Republicans. But if you have people that are basically Republicans, they don't like being out of office. And they're going to stick with whoever their Republican nominee is.
我们在堕胎权问题上可能都是对的。我们可能在吸引温和派共和党人的一些经济政策上也是对的。但如果你面对的是本质上的共和党人，他们不喜欢失去职位。他们会坚持支持他们的共和党候选人。
Of course, the thing that bothers these Republicans the most about Bill Clinton, his waffling on the issues, is something that the presumptive Republican nominee does plenty of as well. Bob Dole has gone back and forth on the "No new taxes" pledge. For a while, when Pat Buchanan was scoring lots of votes with economic populism, Republican-style, Bob Dole tried to pick it up. Bob Dole even wavered on abortion rights a few weeks ago on television. But as Brian Castle on our panel pointed out, our panel still prefers Bob Dole's wavering to the president's.
当然，这些共和党人对比尔·克林顿最感到困扰的事——他在议题上的左右摇摆——同样也是这位准共和党候选人做得非常多的事情。鲍勃·多尔在“不加税”承诺上反反复复。有一段时间，当帕特·布坎南以共和党风格的经济民粹主义获得大量选票时，鲍勃·多尔也试图效仿。几周前，鲍勃·多尔甚至在电视上对堕胎权立场动摇。但正如我们小组的布莱恩·卡斯尔指出的，我们小组仍然更倾向于多尔的摇摆，而不是总统的摇摆。
Well, Bob Dole certainly has made some changes in his positions over a period of time. But I guess I'd have to believe that someone who's spent so many years in Washington, who has learned the process as well as Bob Dole, does have some base beliefs. And I believe that. And I really have a hard time believing that the current president does. I think Bob Dole would be much preferred to President Clinton, even with a waffle here or there.
嗯，鲍勃·多尔在一段时间内确实改变了一些立场。但我认为我愿意相信，一个在华盛顿度过了这么多年、对流程如此了解的人，确实有一些基本信仰。我相信这一点。但我很难相信现任总统有。我认为鲍勃·多尔远胜于克林顿总统，即使他这里那里有些摇摆。
See, because I wonder, as somebody observing this process, if in the end, whether it's Dole or Clinton in the White House, if we'll end up with significantly different policies coming out of the White House. That is, under the Clinton presidency, what we've seen is the debate driven by the Republicans in Congress. And that's certain to continue even in a Dole presidency. And the president, if he's a kind of accommodator, who either Clinton or Dole is, will simply follow the political tide to where it goes and get similar results.
看，作为这个过程的观察者，我在想，如果最终无论是多尔还是克林顿入主白宫，我们是否会看到白宫出台截然不同的政策。也就是说，在克林顿执政下，我们所看到的辩论是由国会的共和党人推动的。即使在多尔执政时期，这种情况也肯定会继续。而如果总统是一个调节者（克林顿或多尔皆是如此），他只会顺应政治潮流，得到类似的结果。
Well, I think-- to some extent, I wanted to offer a bit of a reality check, because I think that even if we have a Republican president come in, we'll have most likely a Republican Congress at the same time. The Republican ideas will then become law in some form. They may not be the exact form that we want at one particular period of time, but the country will trend in that direction. And I believe that's good for the country.
好吧，我认为在一定程度上，我想要提供一点现实检验，因为我认为即使我们迎来了一位共和党总统，我们也极有可能同时拥有一个共和党控制的国会。共和党的想法将以某种形式成为法律。它们可能不是我们在特定时期想要的精确形式，但国家会朝着那个方向发展。我相信这对国家是有好处的。
Diane, what about you?
黛安，你呢？
I would vote for Bob Dole, even with my concerns, because I would view him as a facilitator of a Republican Congress. And that is where my hope lies, that together, we could see progress.
我会投票给鲍勃·多尔，即使有我的顾虑，因为我会视他为共和党国会的推动者。我的希望在于，只要齐心协力，我们就能够看到进步。
So you don't see President Clinton as being a kind of moderate Republican who happens to simply go under the name of Democrat?
所以你不认为克林顿总统是一个恰好以民主党名义行事的温和派共和党人？
I think Bill Clinton has proven that if we want moderate Republicans, he'll be a moderate Republican. If we would like a lounge singer, he'd be a lounge singer.
我认为比尔·克林顿已经证明，如果我们想要温和派共和党人，他就会是温和派共和党人。如果我们想要一个酒廊歌手，他就会是酒廊歌手。
Will Tinken, Diane Cohen, Brian Castle, and Dan Parisi.
威尔·廷肯、黛安·科恩、布莱恩·卡斯尔和丹·帕里西。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "LOVE ME" BY ELVIS PRESLEY]
[音乐播放 - 埃尔维斯·普雷斯利的《爱我》]
Act Two, The Economy. And let's begin this act with the man who made the economy a national issue again and the man who he steals all his best lines from.
第二幕，经济。让我们从那个让经济再次成为全国性议题的人，以及那个剽窃他所有妙语的人开始。
I believe in free enterprise. I believe in capitalism. But I believe we all ought to share in the prosperity.
我信仰自由企业。我信仰资本主义。但我认为我们都应该分享繁荣。
We think corporations should make profits. We support international free trade. But corporate greed is skewing our economy.
我们认为企业应该盈利。我们支持国际自由贸易。但企业贪婪正在扭曲我们的经济。
I think it's wrong for us to put our own workers into dog-eat-dog competition. People in Mexico make $1 an hour.
我认为让我们自己的工人进行你死我活的竞争是错误的。墨西哥人每小时挣 1 美元。
The American worker can't compete with the Mexican worker, can't compete with the Chinese worker. We cannot compete with slave labor. And we should not have to.
美国工人无法与墨西哥工人竞争，也无法与中国工人竞争。我们无法与奴隶劳工竞争。我们不应该面对这种情况。
It is wrong to force our workers to compete with people who make shoes in China for $0.25 an hour.
强迫我们的工人与在中国以每小时 0.25 美元制造鞋子的人竞争是错误的。
Well, that was Patrick J. Buchanan. And did you ever wonder what that J stands for, huh? Could it be, could it be Jesse? Well, no. It couldn't. And of course, Patrick J. Buchanan's prescriptions for our nation are very different than those offered by Jesse Jackson.
好吧，那是帕特里克·J·布坎南。你有没有想过那个 J 代表什么，嗯？可能是杰西吗？好吧，没有。不可能是。当然，帕特里克·J·布坎南为我国开出的药方与杰西·杰克逊提供的截然不同。
Thanks to Patrick Buchanan, we've had about a month of front-page, front-burner discussion of what is happening in the economy. And to review those facts briefly, I find one phrase coming to my lips. It is a phrase, I have to say, that has never come to my lips before, kind of a radio phrase, and that phrase is "Let's do the numbers."
多亏了帕特里克·布坎南，我们有一个月的时间在头条新闻上讨论经济正在发生什么。简单回顾一下这些事实，我嘴边蹦出了一个短语。我得说，这是一个我以前从未说过的短语，一种广播腔，“让我们看看数字吧”。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "WE'RE IN THE MONEY" BY DAVE MCKENNA]
[音乐播放 - 戴夫·麦肯纳的《我们在赚钱》]
A New York Times survey shows that 1/3 of all American households have had someone laid off since 1980. 1/10 of the adults in this country say that a layoff precipitated a major family crisis. And while most people who get laid off do find new jobs, 2/3 of them do not find jobs that paid as much as their old jobs. Median wages in this country have fallen 3% since 1979, adjusted for inflation, while stock prices have set record levels and corporate profits have risen.
《纽约时报》的一项调查显示，自 1980 年以来，三分之一的美国家庭有人被裁员。十分之一的美国成年人表示，裁员引发了严重的家庭危机。虽然大多数被裁员的人确实找到了新工作，但三分之二的人没有找到工资和以前一样高的工作。经通胀调整后，我国的中位工资自 1979 年以来下降了 3%，而股价创下历史新高，企业利润也在增加。
And one way that lots of businesses have helped their bottom lines is by replacing full-time workers with temporary workers and with contract workers. And one sign of the times is that the largest employer in the United States, outside of the government of course, the largest private employer is now a temp agency, Manpower, Incorporated. They send out 800,000 temps a year. And to give you a sense of just how big that is, let's compare that with some other numbers. Could we have that music again, please?
许多企业帮助提高底线的一种方式是用临时工和合同工取代全职工人。一个时代标志是，美国最大的雇主——当然是政府除外——现在是一家临时工代理机构：Manpower 公司。他们每年派出 80 万名临时工。为了让你感受一下这个规模有多大，让我们和其他数字对比一下。能再放一遍那段音乐吗？
[MUSIC PLAYING - "WE'RE IN THE MONEY" BY DAVE MCKENNA]
[音乐播放 - 戴夫·麦肯纳的《我们在赚钱》]
General Motors only has 347,000 employees in North America. Boeing only has 106,000.
通用汽车在北美只有 34.7 万名员工。波音公司只有 10.6 万名。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "WE'RE IN THE MONEY" BY DAVE MCKENNA]
[音乐播放 - 戴夫·麦肯纳的《我们在赚钱》]
Wouldn't it be irritating if every time somebody says a number on the radio, they would just be going along, and they'd just be talking about this and that and this and that, and then suddenly they'd mention 14, and you hear--
如果每次有人在电台上说出一个数字时，他们只是在那儿聊着这个和那个，突然提到 14，你就听到——
[MUSIC PLAYING - "WE'RE IN THE MONEY" BY DAVE MCKENNA]
[音乐播放 - 戴夫·麦肯纳的《我们在赚钱》]
It would be like some weird, distorted, adult Sesame Street nightmare, is what it would be.
那感觉就像某种怪异、扭曲的成人版《芝麻街》噩梦。
Although it is the largest employer in the country, when you visit Manpower's downtown Chicago office, it doesn't feel like it's the outpost of a corporate giant. It feels like what it is, a small office, just seven people, with the idiosyncrasies of any small office. For example, where other offices might use Post-it notes or those "While you were out" message pads, these people use coasters, round, with gold borders, left over from some promotional something years ago. But Manpower is as good a vantage point as any for observing trends in the economy. Manpower spokesperson Stephanie Black says that in the last five years, the nature of the temp business has changed a lot as companies have looked for ways to lay off permanent staff and replace them, as needed, with temps.
虽然它是全国最大的雇主，但当你访问 Manpower 位于芝加哥市中心的办公室时，感觉它并不像是一家企业巨头的前哨站。它感觉就像它本来面目：一个只有七个人的小办公室，带有任何小办公室都有的怪癖。例如，其他办公室可能会使用便利贴或“您不在时”留言垫，而这些人使用的是圆形的、带金边的杯垫，这是多年前某种促销活动留下的。但 Manpower 是观察经济趋势的一个极佳有利位置。Manpower 发言人斯蒂芬妮·布莱克表示，在过去五年里，由于公司寻求裁减长期员工并根据需要用临时工取而代之，临时工业务的性质发生了很大变化。
The business environment has changed enough where with the competitive global market, they need to maintain a core amount of staff that is productive and that they keep for all the time. And then they fill in for special projects or peak periods or seasonal fluctuations by using temporary help.
商业环境发生了足够大的变化，在全球竞争市场中，他们需要维持核心数量的高效人员并长期保留。然后通过使用临时帮助来填补特殊项目、高峰期或季节性波动。
While Manpower has been the beneficiary of these changes with the increased business, Stephanie Black takes pains to say that Manpower did not create the shift in the way that corporations hire or lay off workers. It simply responded.
虽然 Manpower 受益于这些变化，但斯蒂芬妮·布莱克极力表示，Manpower 并没有创造企业雇用或解雇工人的这种转变。它只是做出了回应。
It responded well, though. Some companies use so many dozens of temps all the time that Manpower sends a full-time Manpower representative to work on-site at the company to coordinate all the temps. And while 40% of Manpower's business is office workers and 40% is industrial workers, the fastest-growing part of its business, rising from nothing to 20% just in the last few years, is a category whose very existence tells you a lot about what's going on in the economy. These are technical workers.
不过，它应对得很好。一些公司一直使用几十名临时工，以至于 Manpower 派出全职代表在公司现场工作，以协调所有临时工。虽然 Manpower 40% 的业务是办公文员，40% 是工业工人，但增长最快的部分——在过去几年里从零增加到 20%——是一个其存在本身就告诉你经济中正在发生什么的类别：技术工人。
Computer programmers, LAN administrators, CAD designers, chemists, biologists-- I mean, all sorts of different types of assignments. And many of those are project-based assignments, where they last six months. Come in, install a new network. Six months later, it's over with. They don't want to hire someone. A company doesn't want to bring someone in full-time for a position that's only going to last six months.
计算机程序员、局域网管理员、CAD 设计师、化学家、生物学家——我是说，各种各样的任务。其中许多是基于项目的任务，持续六个月。进来，安装一个新网络。六个月后，任务结束。他们不想雇用某人。公司不想为了一个只持续六个月的职位而全职雇用某人。
This is the kind of work that 10 or 15 years ago might have been done by full-time employees. Now having said all that, it's important to note that one reason that Manpower has become the largest employer in the country is that it gives the people who work for it a fairly good deal, health insurance, paid vacation, and decent money. Skilled secretaries from the Chicago office make from $9 an hour to $16, and Manpower will train them to do particular jobs that it knows there's a market for.
这是 10 或 15 年前可能由全职员工完成的工作。说了这么多，需要注意的是，Manpower 成为全国最大雇主的一个原因是，它为员工提供了相当不错的条件：健康保险、带薪假期和体面的薪水。芝加哥办公室的熟练秘书每小时挣 9 到 16 美元，Manpower 会培训她们从事特定工作，因为他们知道这些工作有市场。
But to get to the bottom of what it's like to be a temp in today's economy, we at this radio program decided we needed to go to the source. And so we hired two temp workers ourselves. And when they showed up at the radio station, we told them that their job while they were working for us was to prepare their own radio stories about what it's like to be a temp.
但为了了解当今经济中当临时工是什么感觉，我们在节目中决定从源头找起。所以我们雇了两名临时工。当他们出现在电台时，我们告诉他们，他们为我们工作期间的任务是准备自己的广播故事，讲述当临时工的感受。
The two guys we got came from an agency called Labor Temps, whose motto is "Yes, we can." As opposed to most of the temp agencies we called with this assignment, who told us, no, they could not. Our two temp workers were named Lee and Tito. And they normally don't get sent to office jobs like this. Normally, these guys do light industrial work, general labor, factory work. Two of our producers, Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike, took them into the radio studio with a list of possible questions they might use in preparing their radio reports about being a temp.
我们找的这两个人来自一家名为“劳工临时工”（Labor Temps）的代理机构，他们的座右铭是“是的，我们可以”。与我们联系的大多数代理机构不同，后者告诉我们，不，他们不能。我们的两名临时工叫李和铁托。他们通常不会被派往像这样的办公室工作。通常，这些人从事轻工业工作、一般劳动力、工厂工作。我们的两位制作人，艾利克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克，带着他们列出的一系列可能用于准备广播报道的问题，将他们带进了录音室。
Check this one out. Does temping pay the bills, or do you have another job? And describe [? your family. ?]
听听这个。当临时工能支付账单吗，还是你有另一份工作？描述一下你的家庭。
You got to have another job.
你必须得有另一份工作。
You're damn real.
你说得太对了。
I can't see-- well, no, some people work full-time at their temp. But I don't see how you live unless you live 80 in a house.
我看不出——好吧，不，有些人全职当临时工。但我看不出你怎么生活，除非你住在一栋房子里。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交叉谈话]
You're not going to get rich doing this, that's for sure.
做这个肯定发不了财，那是肯定的。
Definitely.
绝对的。
But you keep a hot tortilla on the table.
但你至少能让餐桌上有块热玉米饼吃。
That's Lee, who made the little tortilla joke towards Tito. He was constantly ribbing him with these little ethnic-- I don't even know the word that we should use here in polite company on the radio, just a little ethnic ribbing. And just so you know, Tito gave as good as he got. Here's how he described Lee when we asked him to describe Lee for our stories.
那是李，他对铁托开了那个玉米饼的玩笑。他经常用这种带有民族色彩的——我甚至不知道在这个电台上该用什么词，就叫带有民族色彩的打趣。你要知道，铁托的反击也很犀利。这是我们在要求他描述李时，他给出的评价。
Long-haired, North side white boy. If I didn't know him and be walking down on the street, I'd think he's a pot-smoking, hooker-buying, drinking, just listening to rock and roll, banging his head into walls, and bar hanging out all the time type of guy.
长头发，北区的白人男孩。如果我不认识他，在街上走着，我会以为他是个吸毒、买妓女、喝酒、只听摇滚乐、整天撞墙、在酒吧混日子的人。
I should say that they seemed to have a lot of fun doing their stories, despite these two little quotes, as you will hear presently. The assignment was profile your fellow temp. So in other words, Lee interviewed Tito and did a story about Tito's experience. And Tito interviewed Lee and did a story about Lee's experience. We have two reports for you. The first one that we'll hear is the report that Lee prepared about Tito.
我得说，尽管有这两句小引用，但他们似乎在制作故事时玩得很开心，正如你一会儿会听到的。任务是介绍你的临时工伙伴。换句话说，李采访铁托，写了一个关于铁托经历的故事；而铁托采访李，写了一个关于李经历的故事。我们有两份报告。第一份是我们听到的李为铁托准备的报道。
Hi, I'm Lee. I work at Labor Temps with Tito. Tito, he's Puerto Rican, young, about 21. He's got tattoos, gym shoes, loose-fitting clothes, and a kind of "what's up for lunch" attitude. When you work at a Labor Temp, you get up early in the morning and go to an old garage-looking place and wait around with a bunch of people waiting to get work.
嗨，我是李。我和铁托在“劳工临时工”工作。铁托是波多黎各人，年轻，大约 21 岁。他有纹身，穿着运动鞋，衣服宽松，有一种“午饭吃什么”的态度。当你为“劳工临时工”工作时，你早上起得很早，去一个看起来像旧车库的地方，和一群人一起等候分配工作。
It's two steps, one small one and one big one. Stand on it like a little stair. Maybe four people will fit there a little uncomfortable, three people comfortably standing right there [? unaccounted. ?]
分两步，一个小台阶一个大台阶。像个小楼梯一样站在上面。也许四个人挤在那里会不舒服，三个人站着刚好 [无法辨认]。
OK, you go there, you'll have at least 10 people standing there, without exaggerating, on that one step, holding on to the edge. "Come on, send me, send me," and all that type of thing.
好了，你到那里时，至少会有 10 个人站在那里，毫不夸张，在那一个台阶上，抓着边缘。“快点，派我吧，派我吧”，诸如此类的。
So you go there. You might have at least a good 100, 150. OK. And then you might have probably 10 companies that call today. They probably want five people each. That's what, about 50 people? You've got to look at it like that. So that's why people will say you got to be up there in their face, because they got to choose.
所以你去那里。可能至少有 100 到 150 人。好的。然后今天可能只有 10 家公司打电话来。他们可能每家想要 5 个人。那是多少？大约 50 人？你得这样看。这就是为什么人们说你必须得盯着他们看，因为他们得选择。
All kinds of people work at Labor Temps, Mexicans, Puerto Ricans, black, white, lots of women. Everyone's there for a different reason. Some work one day a week for beer money. Some are trying to support their families. For me, it's mostly a part-time thing.
各种各样的人都在“劳工临时工”工作，墨西哥人、波多黎各人、黑人、白人，还有很多女性。每个人都在那里，原因各不相同。有些人每周工作一天挣点啤酒钱。有些人是为了养家糊口。对我来说，这主要是兼职。
My main job is doing some floors with a friend of mine, Mike. I do some graphics. I worked that about six years. I have knowledge in that field. And I do some computer programming, because I went to DeVry a couple years before I ran out of cash.
我的主业是和我朋友迈克一起铺地板。我做一些平面设计。我在那个领域做了大约六年。我有一些相关知识。我还做计算机编程，因为我在没钱之前在德锐大学（DeVry）读过几年。
I started about two years ago at Labor Temps when I was laid off a graphics job. Here's what Tito did before working with Labor Temps.
大约两年前，我在被平面设计工作裁掉后开始在“劳工临时工”工作。这是铁托在去那里之前做的事。
Sell drugs. Well, I was raised in a way of surviving. Surviving, street survival, be streetwise always. So I was always raising-- if you can't make it here, hey, go to that corner.
卖毒品。好吧，我的成长方式是生存。生存，街头生存，总是要懂街头智慧。所以我也总是——如果你在这里混不下去，嘿，去那个街角。
When did you stop?
你什么时候停止的？
When I went to jail.
我进监狱的时候。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
That's where the temp came in.
这就是临时工工作介入的时候。
You go from jail to being a temp.
你从监狱出来就当临时工。
Tito says as he makes about $150 a week at Labor Temps. Selling drugs, he can make five times that in a single day.
铁托说他在“劳工临时工”每周挣大约 150 美元。卖毒品，他一天就能挣到那五倍的钱。
I look at a temp like a drug.
我看待临时工就像毒品。
How? How's that?
怎么说？
A female gets you to do it. The female gets you to do it. I mean, the way I got into Labor Temps--
有个女人让你去干。那个女人让你去干。我的意思是，我进入“劳工临时工”的方式——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Explain yourself.
解释一下。
The way I got into Labor Temps was I had just finished coming into Chicago not too long ago, either. And I was staying with this female. I met this female. She liked me, whatever. We moved in together.
我进入“劳工临时工”的方式是，我没多久前刚到芝加哥。我和这个女人住在一起。我遇到了这个女人。她喜欢我什么的。我们搬到了一起。
And then well, "Why don't you go to this agency?" It was a block away. So I went. If it wasn't for her, I would've never got in there. And it's like drugs. You know what I'm saying? You don't do that to every drug. But if it's your girlfriend, and she's like, "Come on, honey, please, please, please," you're going to do it eventually.
然后她说，“你为什么不去这家代理机构？”它就在一个街区外。所以我去了。如果不是她，我永远不会去那里。这就像毒品。你知道我的意思吗？你并不是对每种毒品都这样。但如果那是你的女朋友，她一直说，“来吧，亲爱的，求求你，求求你”，你最终还是会去干的。
Temp agencies and the factories which call these agencies for temporary workers don't care that Tito spent six months in county jail. They don't care because they're mostly jobs nobody wants, garbage jobs. Most jobs that are temp jobs only give minimum wage. It's hard to have any strikes against you like Tito. He didn't finish the eighth grade.
临时工代理机构和那些打电话给他们要人的工厂根本不在乎铁托在县监狱待了六个月。他们不在乎，因为那大部分是没人愿意干的工作，垃圾工作。大多数临时工作只给最低工资。如果你像铁托一样有污点，就很难找到工作。他甚至没读完八年级。
I think the people that say "Yeah, we'll call you," and they never call you, I think that's what it is. You know, when you apply, did you finish school? Should I be honest? OK. I'll be honest. They say, OK, we'll call you. And they just throw it out. Once they see the school thing, it's over.
我想那些说“好的，我们会给你打电话”却从不打的人，我想就是这样。你知道，当你申请时，你会读完学校了吗？我该诚实吗？好的。我会诚实。他们说，好吧，我们会给你打电话。然后他们就把申请表扔了。一旦看到学校那栏，就完了。
For Your Radio Playhouse, I'm Lee, the temp.
对于《你的广播剧场》，我是临时工李。
Hopefully, one day, I'm hoping, wishing I'll be at that level where I don't have to worry about waking up in the morning and, "Damn, are they going to send me to work today or not?" I'll be waking up in the morning saying, "I have to go to work. Damn, I'm going to be late for work. Honey, uh--" you know, "Breakfast, where's my breakfast? My lunch, hurry up," all that type of thing.
希望有一天，我希望、祈祷我能达到那个水平，不用担心早起，“该死，他们今天会派我去工作吗？”我会早起说，“我得去上班。该死，我要迟到了。亲爱的，呃——”你知道，“早餐，我的早餐在哪？我的午餐，快点，”诸如此类的。
Family, kids running around, kiss a kid goodbye and whatever. The dog, kick him out of the way because he's in front of the door. All that type of thing.
家庭，孩子们跑来跑去，亲吻孩子说再见之类的。狗，把它踢到一边，因为它挡在门口。诸如此类的。
Well, that was the story that Lee did about Tito. Next, we have the story that Tito did about Lee.
好吧，那是李为铁托做的报道。接下来，是铁托为李做的报道。
I'm Tito. I work with Lee. Lee's been temping a lot longer than me, and he's seen some crazy jobs. He's worked at different agencies, but he's been in Labor Temps the longest. Lee had one assignment through an agency that lasted a whole year.
我是铁托。我和李一起工作。李当临时工的时间比我长多了，他见过一些疯狂的工作。他在不同的代理机构工作过，但在“劳工临时工”待得最久。李通过一家代理机构接到过一个持续了整整一年的任务。
That's the funny thing. Temporary doesn't mean "short." It means no benefits, no pensions, no job security. That's why they hire temp workers. Some companies run on temp workers, all three shifts. They keep the smallest possible staff of full-time workers, just to keep everything running and organized.
有趣的地方就在这里。临时工并不意味着“短暂”。它意味着没有福利、没有养老金、没有工作保障。这就是他们雇用临时工的原因。有些公司全靠临时工，全部三个班次。他们保留最少数量的长期全职员工，只是为了让一切保持运转和有序。
There's maybe five employees, and they have three shifts running. And they're all temps, shifts after shifts of temps.
可能只有五个长期员工，但有三个班次在运行。他们全都是临时工，班次接着班次。
30 here, 20 here.
这里 30 个，那里 20 个。
They'll have three different companies in there with three different sets of temps.
他们会有三家不同的公司在那里，配三组不同的临时工。
Yeah, that's true.
是的，没错。
Most places we go, though, there's a mix of permanent and temp workers. It's a weird relationship. Sometimes the bosses treat you better than the permanents. Sometimes they treat you worse. Sometimes we work faster than the permanents, and they don't like it. They'll mess with you.
不过，我们去的大多数地方，都有长期工和临时工的混合。这是一种奇怪的关系。有时候老板对待你比对长期工好。有时候他们对待你更差。有时候我们工作得比长期工快，他们不喜欢这样。他们会搞你。
Once, Lee worked at a factory that made tar sealers. The tar sealers were delivered through these big pipes.
有一次，李在一家制造焦油密封胶的工厂工作。密封胶是通过大管子输送的。
All of a sudden, you hear this gurgling in the whole system.
突然，你听到整个系统里发出咕噜咕噜的声音。
[GURGLING]
[咕噜声]
Everybody took off. I'm the temp. Every takes off diving behind things and hiding. And this is all a matter of seconds. I see this happening, so I turn around and start running, diving behind a skid or something. And this big air bubble comes out, and this ooze just splatters all over.
每个人都跑了。我是临时工。每个人都跳着躲在东西后面。这一切只在几秒钟内发生。我看到这一幕，于是转身跑，躲在一块滑板之类的东西后面。然后那个大气泡出来，粘液四处飞溅。
Everybody's laughing, man. I said, "Why didn't you tell me?" "Forgot." So every once in a while, it gets a big bubble in the system. And if you don't work there, you'll never notice.
每个人都在笑，伙计。我说，“为什么不告诉我？”“忘了。”所以偶尔系统里就会有个大气泡。如果你不在那里工作，你永远不会注意到。
Sometimes, companies offer you full-time jobs. That happened to me once, but it fell through at the last minute. I would take pretty much any full-time job, $5, $6, $7 an hour. Anything's better than $4.25 an hour. Lee feels different.
有时候，公司会提供全职工作。我有一次遇到过，但在最后一刻没成。我几乎愿意接受任何全职工作，每小时 5、6、7 美元。什么都比每小时 4.25 美元好。李的感觉不同。
Nobody wants to pay any money for any kind of skilled labor. I noticed that. Like I'll go to a graphic place, I'll go to a typesetting house, they don't pay anything anymore. We'll give you $5 an hour to run optical [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
没人愿意为任何技能劳动力付钱。我注意到了。比如我去一家图形公司，我去一家排版所，他们现在根本不付钱。他们说给你每小时 5 美元去运行光学 [无法辨认]。
One guy wanted me to work his computer system. Wanted to give me $650. I was like, "Pfft. Give me $20,000, you pay off my education, and I'll do it." Because I said, "No way, man. You're nuts."
有个家伙想让我运行他的计算机系统。想给我 650。我当时就说，“呸。给我 2 万，你把我的学费付了，我就干。”因为我说，“没门，伙计。你疯了。”
Greedy mother--
贪婪的混蛋——
They want to pay little for certain work that takes years' experience.
他们想为那些需要多年经验的工作支付很少的钱。
For Your Radio Playhouse, I'm Tito the temp.
对于《你的广播剧场》，我是临时工铁托。
You know what's the funny part about all this? If we walked down the straight, we would never admit that we work in an agency. But we will go on live radio for it. I mean, go on radio, have our voices on radio saying we work for an agency.
你知道这里最滑稽的部分吗？如果我们走在大街上，我们永远不会承认我们在代理机构工作。但我们会为此去现场电台。我的意思是，上电台，让我们的声音出现在电台里，说我们在为代理机构工作。
Get some weird jobs out of them.
从他们那儿得到一些奇怪的工作。
So why would you never admit that you worked at an agency?
那你为什么永远不会承认你在代理机构工作？
Because out there, it's an embarrassing thing. It's like a person that-- You're a low-life. You're a nobody.
因为在外面，那是一件丢人的事。这就像一个人——你是个下等人。你是个无名小卒。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "IT WAS A GOOD DAY" BY ICE CUBE]
[音乐播放 - 冰块的《美好的一天》]
OK, so to have music to end the story, I asked both of you guys-- Tito and Lee are here in the studio with me-- I asked you both to bring in some music. Tito, this is the song that you brought in. It's off a cassette. What are we hearing? Pull up to the mic.
好的，为了用音乐结束故事，我问你们俩——铁托和李都在录音室——我问你们俩带点音乐来。铁托，这是你带来的歌。它来自一盘磁带。我们在听什么？靠近麦克风。
Ice Cube, "It Was a Good Day."
冰块的《美好的一天》。
And why did you choose this song to come after your guys' story?
你为什么选择这首歌作为你们故事的结尾？
Because he talks about it being a good day. Nothing happened. Nothing bad happened. No cops messed with you today. No gangbangers messed with you. Everything went smooth today. That's what it meant, happening to me, just running smooth.
因为他谈论的是美好的一天。什么都没发生。什么坏事都没发生。今天没有警察找麻烦。没有帮派成员找麻烦。今天一切都很顺利。这就是它的意思，发生在我身上，一切都进展顺利。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "IT WAS A GOOD DAY" BY ICE CUBE]
[音乐播放 - 冰块的《美好的一天》]
OK, Lee, so what'd you bring? You have a tape here somewhere.
好的，李，你带来了什么？你磁带在哪儿？
Right there.
就在那儿。
Let's see. OK.
让我们看看。好的。
Well, I wanted to play Nugent's "Stranglehold," because it's my favorite song. But it's kind of long. So I figured the mood working for temps, I figured Johnny Cash and Folsom Prison song would be the best.
嗯，我想放纽金特的《扼杀》，因为这是我最喜欢的歌。但这有点长。所以我想了想当临时工的情绪，我想约翰尼·卡什的《福尔瑟姆监狱蓝调》可能是最好的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Life keeps dragging on.
生活一直在拖延。
Go Lee.
李，做得好。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "FOLSOM PRISON BLUES" BY JOHNNY CASH]
[音乐播放 - 约翰尼·卡什的《福尔瑟姆监狱蓝调》]
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Hey, is your boss listening to this show?
嘿，你们的老板在听这个节目吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, they are. Yes, they are.
是的，他们是。是的，他们在听。
Yeah, good luck on Monday. Wait, was that the end of the song? That was the end, huh? We got to rewind it.
好的，祝你们周一好运。等等，那是歌的结尾吗？那是结尾吧？我们得倒带。
Yeah, we got to get the beginning.
是的，我们得找开头。
All right.
好的。
--had it coming. I know I can't be free.
——这是罪有应得。我知道我无法自由。
Can't be free.
无法自由。
But those people keep a-movin', and that's what tortures me.
但那些人一直在前进，那正是折磨我的原因。
Lee, if you want to sing, now's your chance.
李，如果你想唱，现在是你的机会。
I was playing this all day where we were working.
我们工作时我整天都在放这个。
Is that true?
是真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Where were you guys out today?
你们今天在哪里工作？
It's Water Warehouse. They sell products for pools and spas and all types of things.
在水仓库。他们卖泳池和水疗产品之类的。
All right. Now let's let the song play out. We got to do a little break, and then we're going to come back. OK? We have more stuff. Lisa Buscani, a tour of an economic development project, and we're going to talk to you guys a little bit more. OK? So stay tuned.
好的，现在让我们放完这首歌。我们得休息一下，然后回来。好的？我们还有更多内容。丽莎·布斯卡尼，关于一个经济发展项目的参观，我们还要和你们聊聊。好的？所以敬请期待。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "FOLSOM PRISON BLUES" BY JOHNNY CASH]
[音乐播放 - 约翰尼·卡什的《福尔瑟姆监狱蓝调》]
Our program continues in a minute. You're listening to Your Radio Playhouse.
我们的节目一分钟后继续。你正在收听《你的广播剧场》。
It's Your Radio Playhouse . OK, well Tito and Lee, you guys are both still here. Wait, let me get that Folsom Prison music going here. Hold on.
这里是《你的广播剧场》。好的，铁托和李，你们俩都还在。等等，让我把那首《福尔瑟姆监狱》的音乐放出来。等等。
Oh no.
哦，不。
So we can get some background music. And you guys are still looking for jobs, right?
这样我们可以有些背景音乐。你们俩还在找工作，对吧？
Definitely.
绝对的。
And so people who are listening to the radio story, they could hear about some of the things you do. I guess we should set this up, so we're going to station Alix Spiegel at our Your Radio Playhouse phone. If you have a job-- now what kind of job are you guys looking for here?
所以听广播的人可以听到你们所做的一些事情。我想我们应该设置一下，我们将让艾利克斯·斯皮格尔驻守在我们的《你的广播剧场》电话旁。如果你有一份工作——你们在找什么样的工作？
Anything.
什么都行。
Anything. OK, pretty much that narrows it down. What kind of pay range?
什么都行。好的，这基本上缩小了范围。薪水范围呢？
Whatever. Like I said, anything's better than $4.25.
随便。就像我说的，什么都比 4.25 美元好。
You drive one hard bargain here, Tito. I think exploitation is about to happen.
铁托，你真是个强硬的谈判者。我想剥削即将发生。
I could use a job that stretches your brain.
我可以接受一份能锻炼大脑的工作。
All right. All right. You could hear these guys. I can tell you they were our employees for three days. They came in on time. They were prompt. They were courteous. They were a pleasure to have around.
好的，好的。你们听到了。我告诉你们，他们当了我们三天员工。他们按时到达。他们迅速。他们有礼貌。拥有他们真是种荣幸。
Our phone number here is 832-3380. An operator is standing by. Let's see if we can hustle you guys up a job in the next 20 minutes. And if you're not at a phone now, but you've got a job for these guys, call us during the week here at the radio station, 832-3380 in the 312.
我们的电话号码是 832-3380。操作员随时待命。让我们看看能不能在接下来的 20 分钟内帮你们找到工作。如果你现在没电话，但你有工作给他们，在工作日打电话给我们，号码是芝加哥区号 312 的 832-3380。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "FOLSOM PRISON BLUES" BY JOHNNY CASH]
[音乐播放 - 约翰尼·卡什的《福尔瑟姆监狱蓝调》]
Act Three, Dad. Well, we asked Lisa Buscani if she had anything to contribute to our program today about the economy. Lisa is a Chicago poet and writer, performer, winner of the National Poetry Slam, now resides in New York City. And she said she did have something. She had a story about her father.
第三幕，爸爸。我们问丽莎·布斯卡尼对今天的经济节目有什么贡献。丽莎是芝加哥的一位诗人和作家、表演者，全国诗歌大满贯冠军，现居纽约市。她说她有东西。这是一个关于她父亲的故事。
When I remember him during that time, that time that will exist "forever," in quote marks, emphasized heavily to save the family from having to actually discuss it at length, it is morning. It is always morning because no matter how many talk shows or war movies he stayed up to watch the night before, he rises with the sun or its winter absence.
当我在那个时期想起他时，那个将“永远”存在的时间（重音强调，以挽救家庭免于实际详细讨论它），那是早晨。总是早晨，因为无论他前一天晚上熬夜看了多少脱口秀或战争电影，他都会随着太阳或它在冬日的缺席而起床。
He rises because there is work in the morning. There always has been. Either it was assigned to him, or he found it himself. But there is work, and morning is the time to begin it.
他起床是因为早上有活儿干。一直都是这样。要么是分配给他的，要么是他自己找到的。但确实有工作，早晨是开始工作的时间。
I hear his knees popping as he sits at the kitchen table with black coffee and his cigs to read two papers, the Toledo Blade and the Detroit Free Press. Two papers because that would lower the odds, that would double the chances, increase the opportunities to find work, work that he has recently lost. When I see him, there is no work.
我听见他坐在厨房桌旁，喝着黑咖啡，抽着烟，读着两份报纸——《托莱多刀锋报》和《底特律自由新闻报》，膝盖发出咔哒声。读两份报纸是因为这能降低赔率，能增加一倍的机会，增加寻找工作的机会——他最近失去了工作。当我看到他时，没有工作。
It is northwestern Ohio in the middle of its continuous recession. He has shaken both papers of all of their news, and there is no work. It is all he can do to keep from dropping his pride like the seventh veil and answering the aluminum siding or used car sales ads.
这是俄亥俄州西北部，正处于持续不断的经济衰退中。他抖动着两份报纸，上面没有任何新闻，也没有工作。他能做的最好的事就是不让自己像掉落第七层面纱那样彻底丧失尊严，而去回答铝壁板或二手车推销的广告。
Some days are better than others, though. On the good days, there is work. And he circles the ad with an exuberant, victorious red pen and heads upstairs to his office. His office, for as long as I can remember, had a huge desk cluttered with spec sheets and promotional brochures featuring whatever he was selling at the time, bright, four-colored photos of appliances or mattresses arranged in ways that would prove these items to be necessary, essential to the customer's well-being and happiness. Whatever he was selling, it was always essential and necessary.
不过，有些日子比另一些好。在好日子里，有工作。他用那支充满活力、胜利的红色钢笔圈出广告，然后上楼去他的办公室。我的记忆中，他的办公室里有一张巨大的桌子，堆满了规格表和促销小册子，上面写着他当时正在卖的东西——明亮、四色的电器或床垫照片，排列得仿佛能证明这些物品是必需的，对顾客的幸福和快乐至关重要。无论他在卖什么，它总是基本的，必要的。
But when I see him, the desk is bare. The clutter has been swept away. Even his answering machine message is empty, because he has no company that he proudly represents, no business cards.
但当我看到他时，桌子是空的。杂物已被清理干净。连他的答录机信息也是空的，因为他没有一家他引以为豪的公司，也没有名片。
Time has become his greatest enemy. His unemployment insurance is running out. He has long since passed the age when most companies will consider hiring him. He leaves the age blank empty on the application form, but personnel managers still rush him through interviews after one look at his tastefully graying temples and some simple math on his job experience.
时间已成为他最大的敌人。他的失业保险快用完了。他早已过了大多数公司会考虑雇用他的年龄。他在申请表上把年龄一栏留空，但人事经理在看了一眼他那充满品味的灰白鬓角，并简单算了一下他的工作经验后，还是会匆忙结束面试。
Time has become a shifting, empty, immemorable thing. Two months becomes six months. Six months becomes a year. He tries to fill it by painting the house and organizing the basement.
时间已成为一种变化的、空虚的、不可记忆的东西。两个月变成六个月。六个月变成一年。他试图通过粉刷房子和整理地下室来填补它。
I see my mom, weak with the weight of it. She's pale from going to work and arriving home without the sun. I see her lips thin and her knuckles whiten as she puts a bill payment off another month, as they max out another credit card, as they second mortgage the house.
我看到我妈妈，被这份沉重压得虚弱。她因为工作和每天没见到太阳就回家而脸色苍白。我看到她的嘴唇变薄，指关节因推迟一个月付账、透支信用卡、二次抵押房子而发白。
It has never been this bad. Together, they put three kids through college, and it was never this bad. She's struggling with her tongue, with her ever-present desire to scream at him, "Do something." Everything they built together is slowly crumbling, and she wonders if they'll survive.
从来没这么糟过。他们一起供三个孩子上了大学，以前从没这么糟。她在舌头上挣扎，在她想对他尖叫“做点什么”的永远存在的欲望中挣扎。他们共同建造的一切正在缓慢崩溃，她想知道他们是否能挺过去。
When I see him, he's typing cover letters, a hesitant, two-fingered pecking on an old Smith Corona with a fading ribbon. The family smiles quietly and rewrites, corrects his grammar, telling him, "Daddy, take this out. You sound too desperate." But after all, you write what you know.
当我看到他时，他正在打求职信，在一台旧的史密斯-科罗纳打字机上犹豫不决地用两根手指敲击，色带已经褪色。家人静静地笑着，改写他的求职信，纠正他的语法，告诉他，“爸爸，把这个删了。你听起来太绝望了。”但归根结底，你写的是你知道的东西。
And what he knows is he has 30 years of experience, 30 years of smiling when he didn't want to, 30 years of forcing laughter into the phone, of looking into narrow, skeptical eyes, of fast food, 30 years of paperwork, of business trips in cut-rate motels, of driving backwater towns in white-out storms. 30 years of the word "no," 30 years of straight commission, which is the hardest, toughest, way to go. And god dammit, that's got to be good enough for someone. He's living with the firm knowledge that there is nothing that he cannot do and the terrifying reality that he will not be allowed to do it.
他知道的是他有 30 年的经验，30 年在不想笑时保持微笑，30 年强迫电话里充满笑声，30 年盯着狭窄、怀疑的眼睛，30 年吃快餐，30 年文书工作，30 年在廉价汽车旅馆出差，30 年在暴风雪中开车走过乡镇。30 年的“不”，30 年的直接佣金，这是最艰难、最严苛的生存方式。该死的，这对某人来说一定足够好了。他生活在一个坚定的信念中：没有什么他做不到的事，以及一个恐怖的现实：他不会被允许去完成它。
I see us talking, my dad and I, about his unemployment and his prospects for the future. Nothing is ever said because most of the time, there is nothing to say. I wish him luck and faith, because sometimes only the intangibles can set things right.
我看到我们父女俩在谈论他的失业和未来前景。什么都没说，因为大部分时间里，无话可说。我祝他好运和信念，因为有时只有无形的东西才能让事情好转。
When I see him, he thinks he is alone. But he is not. All across Ohio, the Midwest, America, thousands of white, middle-aged men just like Dad are attending workshops, haunting placement agencies and training centers, filling their chests with the ghosts of their bravado, straining to understand why what once worked for them does not work any longer. They play their losing game the way they always have, pulling desperately on bootstraps, noses frantically to grindstones.
当我看到他时，他以为他是孤独的。但他不是。在俄亥俄州、中西部、美国各地，成千上万像我爸一样的白人中年男人正在参加讲习班，出入职业介绍所和培训中心，用他们虚张声势的幽灵充盈着胸膛，努力想明白为什么曾经对他们有效的东西现在不再有效了。他们像往常一样玩着他们失败的游戏，绝望地拉着靴带，鼻子疯狂地贴在磨刀石上。
These men refuse to question the validity of the business structures that they've established, a vicious system that whipped around and bit them the first chance it got. It is this ignorant, blind faith that makes me think, "Good. Let the men who made the rules and carry out the policies suffer the consequence of these policies. They chose management's pay scale. Let them live without the protection of a union. Let the most privileged class of our society taste the fear and frustration that the rest of us know on a daily basis."
这些人拒绝质疑他们建立的商业结构的有效性——一个恶毒的系统，在它得到第一个机会时就反咬了他们一口。正是这种无知的、盲目的信仰让我觉得，“好啊。让那些制定规则并执行政策的人尝尝这些政策的后果吧。他们选择了管理的工资标准。让他们在没有工会保护的情况下生活吧。让社会中最特权阶层尝尝我们其他人每天感受到的恐惧和沮丧。”
Then I think of my dad, how he waited, how time weighed him down and wore on him like the sea over stone. I wouldn't wish that on anyone.
然后我想到我爸爸，他等待着，时间是如何像海浪冲刷石头一样压在他身上并消耗他的。我不会希望别人也经历这些。
Act Four, Economic Development, Chicago Style. Well, we as a nation are not helpless in the face of broad economic forces. We can take action. We can spur economic development. Witness one of the high visibility projects put into place by the city of Chicago and the state of Illinois at a cost of $156 million of taxpayer money, Navy Pier.
第四幕，经济发展，芝加哥模式。好吧，作为一个国家，在广泛的经济力量面前我们并非束手无策。我们可以采取行动。我们可以刺激经济发展。见证一个芝加哥市和伊利诺伊州耗资 1.56 亿美元纳税人资金的高能见度项目：海军码头。
Navy Pier is a downtown waterfront project on Lake Michigan, not far from the heart of downtown Chicago, but not in it, either. Lots of cities have development projects like this. There's Faneuil Hall in Boston, Baltimore's Inner Harbor, New York's South Street Seaport.
海军码头是一个位于密歇根湖上的市中心海滨项目，离芝加哥市中心核心区不远，但也并不在其中。许多城市都有这样的开发项目。波士顿有法纳尔大厅，巴尔的摩有内港，纽约有南街海港。
Navy Pier features a big Ferris wheel and the Chicago Children's Museum and one of those IMAX movie theaters. There's convention floor space. There's some shopping and a food court. The atmosphere is that of a second-rate mall anywhere in America. The roof leaks. The food's nothing special. The stores aren't the kind you'd go out of your way to visit.
海军码头有一个巨大的摩天轮、芝加哥儿童博物馆和 IMAX 电影院。有会议展览空间。还有一些商店和美食广场。氛围就像美国任何地方的二流购物中心。屋顶漏水。食物没什么特别的。商店也不是那种你会特地去逛的地方。
We at this radio program are very familiar with Navy Pier because Chicago's public radio station recently moved to a new building located halfway between the Ferris wheel and the convention space. Our staff has spent so many hours walking the drafty hallway between the food court and our offices that associate producer Peter Clowney has committed to memory the song "Here Come the Hawks," the official theme song of Chicago's hockey team that, for a while, for reasons we've never been able to fully understand or explain, played incessantly in the hallway PA system.
我们这个广播节目非常熟悉海军码头，因为芝加哥的公共广播电台最近搬到了一栋位于摩天轮和会议空间中间的新大楼。我们的员工花了无数小时走在美食广场和办公室之间那条通风的走廊上，以至于副制片人彼得·克劳尼已经背熟了《雄鹰来了》，这是芝加哥冰球队的官方主题曲，由于某些我们无法完全理解或解释的原因，它在走廊的广播系统中不停地播放。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "HERE COME THE HAWKS" BY J. SWAYZEE]
[音乐播放 - J. 斯威兹的《雄鹰来了》]
We have watched with fascination some of the strange conventions that have come and gone here at Navy Pier. One day, strolling to the end of the pier for some fresh air, I looked into Exhibit Hall A and saw an entire carnival midway, complete with full-size rides, multicolored lights, loud music, equipment so massive it's hard to comprehend how they even get it indoors. But here it was, under the artificial lights, during the dead of Chicago winter.
我们怀着好奇观看了海军码头里来来去去的一些奇怪会议。有一天，散步到码头尽头呼吸新鲜空气时，我往展厅 A 里看了一眼，看到一个完整的嘉年华游乐场，配有全尺寸游乐设施、五彩灯光、震耳欲聋的音乐，设备如此巨大，以至于很难理解他们是怎么把它搬进室内的。但在芝加哥死寂的冬日里，它就在这人工灯光下。
A few months before, we all gawked at a convention whose purpose was to help small businesses market their products to Generation X. This was, as far as we could determine, American capitalism at a disturbingly odd nadir, sunk so low you didn't want to see it there, trying to market to a generation whose supposed defining characteristic is that it's comprised of non-materialist, non-conformist, slacker types who, above all, resent products being marketed to them.
几个月前，我们都目瞪口呆地看着一个会议，其目的是帮助小企业向 X 一代推销产品。据我们判断，这是美国资本主义在一个令人不安的奇怪最低点，低到你不想看到它在那里，试图向一代人推销，而这一代人所谓的定义特征是他们由非物质主义、不墨守成规、懒散的人组成，最重要的是，他们反感产品向他们推销。
--the contest. He's going to demonstrate karaoke for you. Johnny Vaughan will demonstrate karaoke for you. And we're taking the next four people. I think we have two people signed up for our contest. Johnny Vaughan, we'll start the CD, and we're off.
——比赛。他要为你演示卡拉 OK。约翰尼·沃恩要为你演示卡拉 OK。我们要找下四个人。我想我们有两个报名参加比赛的人。约翰尼·沃恩，我们要放 CD 了，我们开始吧。
Hello.
你好。
We can only wonder if the Generation X karaoke contest would have been more popular had there actually been an audience in the hall to participate. But the Generation X convention was one of the least successful events at the pier. The most important single fact about this $156 million economic development project is that, by all accounts, it is a huge, huge success.
我们只能想，如果展厅里真有观众参与，X 一代卡拉 OK 大赛会不会更受欢迎。但 X 一代会议是码头最不成功的活动之一。关于这个 1.56 亿美元经济发展项目，最重要的一点是，据所有报道，它是一个巨大、巨大的成功。
Crowds are twice as large as anyone expected, three and a half million in just six months. People even came during the winter. And at many stores and restaurants, business is good.
人群数量是预期的两倍，仅仅六个月就有 350 万人次。甚至在冬天也有人来。在许多商店和餐馆，生意不错。
This is by far, I think, our best seller.
到目前为止，我认为这是我们最畅销的。
Describe what this is. This is a T-shirt.
描述一下这是什么。这是一件 T 恤。
It's just a T-shirt. And we have it in both designs. We have just a plain white T-shirt. And what it is kind of a different look of the skyline, of fun, instead of your regular old skyline picture, just a really fun design showing Chicago with a nice little heart world representing the earth.
它只是一件 T 恤。我们有两种设计。我们有普通白 T 恤。这是一种不同风格的天际线，充满乐趣，而不是你平时看到的普通天际线照片，这是一种展现芝加哥的真正有趣的图案，带有一个代表地球的可爱小爱心世界。
Mary Beth Pullman owns the store Oh Yes Chicago, which looks like an upscale Gap store with blond wood floors, selling T-shirts and caps with the word Chicago on them in various designs. None of them, she'll tell you proudly, with the hackneyed old Al Capone, Chicago mobster, Mrs. O'Leary's cow images. The T-shirt she was showing me sells 25 or so on a typical day at $15 a shirt. Most of her customers are from out of town.
玛丽·贝丝·普尔曼拥有“噢是的芝加哥”商店，看起来像一家带有金黄色木地板的高档 Gap 商店，出售上面印有“芝加哥”字样、图案多样的 T 恤和帽子。她会自豪地告诉你，这里没有一件印有老套的阿尔·卡彭、芝加哥黑帮、奥利里夫人的牛之类的图像。她给我看的 T 恤在典型的一天能卖出 25 件左右，每件 15 美元。大多数顾客来自外地。
They're going to maybe come in here, buy something for themselves and for a loved one, whether it be a child or a spousal unit or--
他们也许会进来，为自己和心爱的人买点什么，无论是孩子还是配偶——
These are the kinds of jobs and businesses that have been created so far for $156 million. Mary Beth Pullman's happy at the pier. Her sales have exceeded expectations and projections. But like most businesses anywhere, it takes a while before you realize real profits. The pier's been open less than a year. She figures it'll be another two before the store is comfortably profitable. And in the meantime, she's earning less than she did in her old job renting shopping center space. Fortunately, she has a spousal unit of her own out in the suburbs earning money, so she doesn't have to draw a salary from the store right now.
这就是目前为止 1.56 亿美元创造出的工作岗位和业务。玛丽·贝丝·普尔曼在码头很开心。她的销售额超过了预期和预测。但像任何地方的大多数企业一样，实现真正利润需要一段时间。码头开放还不到一年。她估计还要两年商店才能舒适地盈利。在此期间，她挣得比她在出租购物中心空间的老工作中要少。幸运的是，她在郊区有一个配偶在赚钱，所以她现在不必从店里领薪水。
Any money that I'm taking out of the store is really being put right back in for inventory and such. It's because we are coming in to our peak season. So that's how, I mean, my compensation is I could draw the salary out if I wanted to. But at this point in time, it's in my best interest and the business' best interest to just put it right back in for inventory.
我从店里取出的任何钱基本上都直接放回库存等方面去了。因为我们正进入旺季。所以我的报酬是，如果我想的话，我可以领工资。但在此时此刻，为了我的利益和企业的利益，直接把钱放回库存中是最好的。
This store has seven employees, and they earn between $6.00 and $8.00 an hour, which is about par for Navy Pier. That's $12,000 to $16,000 a year, not much if you're trying to raise a family. But most of the people you see working at the pier are in their 20s and early 30s, just starting out. Nigel, for example, works in the T-shirt store half the week and uses the money to go to college the other half. He lives with his parents, hopes to go to law school, take international law.
这家店有七名员工，每小时收入在 6 到 8 美元之间，这在海军码头属于平均水平。每年 1.2 万到 1.6 万美元，如果你想养家糊口，这并不多。但在码头工作的绝大多数人都在 20 多岁到 30 出头，刚起步。比如奈杰尔，他半周在 T 恤店工作，用钱另一半时间上大学。他和父母住在一起，希望将来去法学院，学习国际法。
I do speak Spanish. I'm bilingual. So in the long run, maybe have some business dealings in Mexico, South America, maybe in Spain. That's what I want to do. For now, I'm just happy working for Mary Beth here at Oh Yes Chicago.
我会说西班牙语。我是双语者。所以从长远来看，也许在墨西哥、南美洲，也许在西班牙做生意。这就是我想做的。现在，我只是很高兴在“噢是的芝加哥”为玛丽·贝丝工作。
In fact, many workers on the Pier said they were glad to have these jobs. They didn't complain. The one maintenance man told me that he made more money at the hair care products company he used to work for, before layoffs sent him to the pier. He was looking for another job.
事实上，码头上的许多员工说他们很高兴有这些工作。他们没有抱怨。那个维修工告诉我，在被裁员送到码头之前，他在那家护肤品公司挣的钱更多。他正在找另一份工作。
Navy Pier officials are tight-lipped about the number of jobs that have been created for $156 million in taxpayer money. They say no economic projection or impact statements were ever done for the project. But after weeks of refusing to provide any numbers for this radio story, they finally turned over a few. Let's do them.
海军码头官员对于 1.56 亿美元纳税人资金创造的工作岗位数量守口如瓶。他们说从未对该项目进行任何经济预测或影响声明。但在拒绝提供任何数字数周后，他们终于交出了一些。让我们看看。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "WE'RE IN THE MONEY" BY DAVE MCKENNA]
[音乐播放 - 戴夫·麦肯纳的《我们在赚钱》]
The Navy Pier Authority says they have 137 full-time and 451 part-time employees. These are the people who work for the pier itself, security people, parking, maintenance. The Navy Pier Authority would not provide information on the salary ranges of its employees, or even a breakdown of employees' jobs. The Pier Authority refused to allow us to interview any pier employees for this report.
海军码头管理局表示他们有 137 名全职员工和 451 名兼职员工。这些人是为码头本身工作的，包括保安、停车场、维修。海军码头管理局不会提供其员工薪资范围的信息，甚至不会提供员工职位的细分。码头管理局拒绝允许我们采访任何码头员工进行报道。
In addition to the pier employees, there are 37 stores and restaurants located on the pier. At the very most, we figure they employ 600 additional people, bringing the pier total, at most, to 1,200 workers. The government put $156 million dollars into the pier. That works out to $130,000 per job at the very least. And remember that more than half of these jobs are part-time.
除了码头员工，码头上还有 37 家商店和餐馆。最多，我们估计他们雇用额外 600 人，使码头总共最多有 1,200 名员工。政府向码头投入了 1.56 亿美元。这算下来每个岗位至少 13 万美元。记住，这些人中超过一半是兼职。
Well, we had no idea if this was good or not, $130,000 per job created. So we called someone to find out. Joan Fitzgerald is a urban planner at the Great Cities Institute at the University of Illinois at Chicago.
好吧，我们不知道每个岗位 13 万美元算不算好。所以我们打电话给某人。琼·菲茨杰拉德是伊利诺伊大学芝加哥分校大城市研究所的城市规划师。
I would say it's a lot of money per job for service sector jobs, and particularly given that the number of those that are-- because you're counting your part-time jobs in there. And chances are those are jobs as shop clerks and so forth. So we're not talking living wage jobs here. It's very high.
我会说对于服务业工作来说，每个岗位花费的钱太多了，特别是考虑到你计算的是兼职工作。而这些工作很可能是店员之类的。所以我们谈论的不是能维持生活的工资。这非常高。
Joan Fitzgerald says that it used to be common for governments to create-- you know, we played that David Brancaccio music, and now I feel like I'm reading exactly like him. Now I'm going to try to read like myself. It's irresistible, once you play that Marketplace music, it has an effect on you that's so profound. All right.
琼·菲茨杰拉德说，政府过去习惯创造每个岗位花费 1 万或 1.2 万美元的工作，但现在出现了一场争夺雇主和企业的竞标战。每个岗位 13 万美元很高，但仍然只是阿拉巴马州为得到一家奔驰工厂所花费的一小部分。琼·菲茨杰拉德说，如果海军码头有助于将游客带到城市，并推动会议和酒店业务，那么这项投资就更有意义。
Joan Fitzgerald-- friends at home, I just want you to try this yourselves. Get a copy of that Dave McKenna "We're in the Money." And good luck finding it, because it's out of print. But let's not even go into that. And then play this thing. And I swear, you start to read like David Brancaccio on Marketplace. Well, I'm just going to read like him. That's what I'm going to do for this section of the story.
你不能仅仅着眼于每个项目本身。你必须将其视为更广泛旅游发展战略的一部分。
Joan Fitzgerald says that it used to be common for governments to create jobs for $10,000 or $12,000 per job, but there's been a bidding war to pull in employers and businesses. $130,000 per job is high, but still a fraction of what Alabama just spent to get a Mercedes-Benz plant. And Joan Fitzgerald says that if Navy Pier helps bring tourists to the city and convention business and hotel business, then the investment makes more sense.
芝加哥城市官员，如规划与发展部副专员格雷格·朗希尼，更希望我们不要试图计算海军码头的每岗位成本。
You can't just look at each project in and of itself. You have to look at it as part of a broader tourism development strategy.
绝对不行。这是一个疯狂的看待问题的方式。该项目不是为了创造工作岗位。
Chicago city officials like Greg Longhini, assistant to the commissioner at the Department of Planning and Development, would prefer if we would not try to come up with a per-job cost at all for Navy Pier.
该项目的目的是什么？
Absolutely not. It's a crazy way to look at the question. The project was not to create jobs.
该项目的目的是恢复一个市政地标，一个宝藏，有点像修复里莱恩斯大楼。我不认为它是一个主要是创造就业或经济发展的项目。
What was the purpose of the project?
所以并没有一种观念认为它的想法是带来某种商业或帮助芝加哥的商业？
The purpose of the project was to restore a civic landmark, a treasure, kind of like the restoring of the Reliance Building. I was not aware of it being a job-generating or primarily an economic development project.
不，我不是说情况不是这样。但开始分析投资所创造的岗位数量是没有意义的。
So there was no notion that the idea of this was to bring some sort of business or help business in Chicago?
那么我们该如何评估海军码头的成功或失败？
No, I'm not saying that that's not the case. But to start analyzing the number of jobs created by the investment doesn't make sense.
我认为我们应该根据公众的看法、有多少人访问、人们对它的评价，以及它是否增加了芝加哥作为居住和访问的好地方的形象来评估海军码头的成功或失败。
So how should we evaluate the success or failure of Navy Pier?
好的，朋友们，观众席里有这么多漂亮的小孩。我们想请所有小家伙上来和我们站在一起，因为我们要为你们唱下一首歌。所以上来站在这里。
I think we should evaluate the success or failure of Navy Pier on how it's viewed by the citizens at large, how many people visit the place, what people think about it, whether or not it adds to the image of Chicago as a good place to live and a good place to visit or not.
在海军码头的中庭，靠近麦当劳和“噢是的芝加哥”，一个名为“海军码头表演者”的无伴奏合唱团从约 60 人的观众中拉出几个三四岁的孩子。
Well, my friends, we've got so many beautiful little kids out here in the audience. We want to ask all of the little ones to come up and join us here on our stage, because we want to sing this next song directly to you guys. So come up here and stand right by us.
[音乐 - 海军码头表演者合唱]
In the middle of the atrium at Navy Pier, near the McDonald's and Oh Yes Chicago, a strolling troupe of a cappella singers called the Navy Pier Players pulls a few three- and four-year-olds from a crowd that numbers about 60.
如果不是为了孩子，你有没有想过就没有圣诞老人了。看看鹳鸟刚才带来了什么，感谢上帝赐予孩子。
[MUSIC - NAVY PIER PLAYERS SINGING]
被抱在各种歌手怀里和膝上的三个孩子茫然地盯着中间远方。每个“海军码头表演者”都打扮成不同的角色。领唱是“大熊队”风格的体育迷。有奥利里夫人，她的牛据说引发了芝加哥大火。有啦啦队长和书呆子大学生，一个穿着模仿祖特装、戴宽边帽的家伙，一个水手女孩，还有一个角色，其卖点仅仅是她喜欢购物。
If it weren't for kids, have you ever thought there wouldn't be a Santa Claus. And look what the stork just brought, thank god for kids.
他们每天演出四场，每周五天。他们流了一身汗，充满了活力，跳舞和唱歌。看到他们在美食广场向一群游客和目瞪口呆的孩子引吭高歌，比如《波西米亚狂想曲》的无伴奏版本，你绝不会认为这是一份轻松的工作。绝不。
The three children being held in various singers' arms and laps stare blankly into the middle distance. Each of the Navy Piers Players is dressed as a different character. The lead singer is a Da Bears-style sports fan. There's Mrs. O'Leary, whose cow supposedly started the Chicago fire. There's a cheerleader and a nerdy college boy, a guy in a mock zoot suit and a wide brim hat, a sailor girl, and a female character whose gimmick is simply that she likes shopping.
上帝保佑美国。这首歌送给海军码头所有的爱国者。1、2、3、4。1、2、3、4。
They do four shows a day, five days a week. And they work up a sweat, all that pep, dancing and singing. Seeing them belt out an a cappella rendition of, say, "Bohemian Rhapsody" in the food court to a group of tourists and stunned-looking children, you do not think this is an easy job. Anything but.
[音乐 - 海军码头表演者合唱]
God bless America. This next song goes out to all the patriots here at Navy Pier. Hut, 2, 3, 4. Hut, 2, 3, 4.
表演结束后，我和那个穿着水手服装的女人谈了谈。她拿着一面美国国旗，每回答一个问题后都向我致敬。
[MUSIC - NAVY PIER PLAYERS SINGING]
是的，我曾在一家日本餐厅打过钢琴。我创办了一家名为“库斯市制作”的小型制作公司，并用它举办了两场演出。我教钢琴。是的。
After the performance, I spoke with this woman, the one in the sailor costume. She carries an American flag and after every answer, gave me a little salute.
现在，所以这是其中之一——你刚才致敬了。
Yeah, I worked in a Japanese restaurant playing the piano. I started a little production company called [? Koose ?] City Productions, and I put on two shows with that. I give piano lessons. Yeah.
是的。
And right now, so this is one of many-- you just saluted.
这是你目前从事的众多工作之一吗？
Yeah.
嗯，这是我的主要工作。
This is one of many jobs that you have right now?
350 人试镜了这八个职位。这可能不是世界上最好的收入，但芝加哥没有多少全职演员和歌手的工作。在两名海军码头官员站在旁边确保没人说出不适当的话的情况下，她说她很高兴得到这份工作。
Well, this is my primary job.
今天的节目由彼得·克劳尼和我制作，艾利克斯·斯皮格尔、南希·厄普代克和多洛雷斯·威尔伯参与。特约编辑杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和保罗·托夫。WBEZ 管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。
350 people auditioned for these eight jobs. It may not be the greatest money in the world, but there aren't many full-time jobs for actors and singers in Chicago. And with two Navy Pier officials standing by to make sure no one said anything inappropriate, she said she was glad to get the work.
[致谢]
Today's program was produced by Peter Clowney and by myself with Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updike, and Dolores Wilber. Contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Paul Tough. WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia.
如果你想购买本期或其他剧场节目的磁带，你可以致电 WBEZ。如果你想为我们的两名临时工铁托或李提供工作，你可以出于那个原因致电我们，尽管我们至少接到了一个电话。312-832-3380，这是我们这里的电话。再说一次，312-832-3380。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
如果你听到答录机，请留言。我们会在有空时回电。你可以通过这个电子邮件地址给我们发邮件，[email protected]。
If you want to buy a tape of this or other Playhouse programs, you can call us at WBEZ. If you want to give jobs to our two temp workers, Tito or Lee, you can call us for that reason, though we have received one call at least. 312-832-3380, our phone number here. Again, 312-832-3380.
我们在 WBEZ 芝加哥广播。下周我们将带着更多关于这种美国生活的故事回来。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
And if you get the answering machine, just leave a message. We'll call you back when we can. You can email us at this email address, [email protected] .
如果转接到语音信箱，请留言。我们会尽快给您回电。您可以发送电子邮件至此地址：[email protected] 。
We broadcast from WBEZ Chicago. We'll be back next week with more stories of this American life. I'm Ira Glass.
我们通过芝加哥WBEZ电台为您广播。下周我们将带来更多关于美国生活的故事。我是艾拉·格拉斯。